c'est vraiment votre tablier de mercy 4
ans bonsoir bonsoir à tous rétabli et
ménager les ça commence les vacances
après tout on est en vacances depuis ce
matin c'est exact nous sommes en
vacances et bien longtemps voyez comment
faire la cuisine pour les hommes vous
allez faire tandis que de me donner
également le petit le petit torchon qui
s'est fait ça vous messieurs quand vous
faites la cuisine chez vous alors qu'une
pomme de terre de pomme de terre jusqu'à
présent aussi je vais faire ce qu'est ce
qu'on va faire une troisième
communautaire 3 les bois alors nous
avons réussi à gagner le titre
le nom de la recette oui 4 je crois que
ça s'applique aux pommes coin de rue les
coins de rue nous ont rien à te faire
joli le royaume c'est bien parce que ces
pommes coin de rue ou 11 ans
effectivement des pommes de couper un
petit peu comme on peut supposer que
sont les coins de rue qui peu de travers
enfin séparé d'entre eux tu es vers une
autre fois vous êtes une recette qui est
d'ailleurs très cool vous savez je ne
ce n'est pas une invention il s'en faut
de beaucoup il ya un restaurant
qu'est ce que c'est un téléspectateur
qui m'a écrit oui il est écouté qui m'a
dit est ce que vous pourriez nous faire
les les steaks forme coin de rue que
l'on mange dans des restaurants et
produits et vous pensez que vous allez
lui donner la recette vous cherchez à la
suite
alors je me suis renseigné à la source
et à yéo alors maintenant nous allons
immédiatement commencé à approcher ces
pauvres c'est à dire les faire cuire
cochise les pocher oui cette ville oui
mais on gauche aussi bien à lui le calot
enfin que dans n'importe quel autre
d'ailleurs en n'importe quelle autre
liquide eux s'ils sont reconnus mais là
le sont sèches pasco et vous depuis déjà
un moment elles sont sous les sunlights
des comme vous faisiez remarquer avec
beaucoup de justesse
tout al'air si nous n'avons pas eu un
été très chaud jusqu'à aujourd'hui les
saints laïcs ne se sont pas arrêtés eux
de chauds ce qui fait que l'on a ici
[Musique]
alors voyons là et nous allons remettre
cette structure un peu plus doucement
c'est à dire devant la changer d'un plot
sur l'autre et primes ainsi que l'on
ajouté une pomme de crise parce que
voilà la radier de me donner une forme
de plus tenir de tels commentaires
couplés une plus parce que voc pour
l'autre entité de friture et pour le
temps que j'ai disponibles doit on
mettre une de plus très détendue
dutoit et aux pompiers dans la réponse
qui sont là par conséquent le danger est
tout de même immigré réduire et limiter
ses vallées alors ça va aller nous
allons laisser cuire
donc restons témoin en continu une
petite histoire à je voulais voir à côté
une petite histoire vue et le support à
midi puis je ne sais pas depuis je ne
sais pas me coin de rue pasquaïen ou les
pommes au coin de rue je vais ont
recoupé une pour bien je l'avais pas et
on l'a quand on les coupe comme ceux ci
on garde un côté beaucoup plus épais que
l'autre et où elles sont en quelque
sorte un espèce de petite pyramide et
lorsqu'on demande pourquoi on les coupe
comme ça parce que ce n'est pas
difficile il ya un côté qui reste très
moelleux et l'autre côté qui reste très
croquant
alors ça me rappelait une histoire
l'histoire d'une dame qui demande au
maître d'hôtel maître d'hôtel je
voudrais un steak mais je ne me pensais
comme tout le monde je veux insister
coupé très épais d'un côté et très mince
de l'autre je veux aussi qu'on le
saisissent à la poêle et qu'on le fasse
cuire au four
parce que je ne veux pas que ce texte
soit cuit sur sur le fourneau il faut
qu'ils soient cuites dans le fourneau je
veux aussi que l'on lepoivre d'un côté
et quand le frotte à l'ail de l'autre
oui c'était très important je veux quand
le sol au dernier moment et que sur ce
steak on ajoute une petite tranche de
beurre frais alors le moteur lit très
bien madame vous avez bien compris la
dame lui dit oui j'ai très bien compris
le dilemmien d'hôtel voulez vous répéter
dit la dame ou oui alors il répète vous
l'institut j'ai fait d'un côté que de
l'autre voulait à y ait d'un côté le
saler poivrer et ses lecteurs il lui
répète exactement tout et il descend à
la cuisine et eddy chef un steak 1
on l'est on le dit pas mais nous
pourrons lui demander un jour si nous le
rencontrons
si vous êtes dans un jour me demande
cette recette je lui demandais comment
ça s'était passé jusque là alors voyez
vous ici nous allons préparer puisque
nous allons avoir à nous en occuper dans
le petit moment nous allons couvre
prépare une petite sauce une petite
sauce extrêmement simple au vin rouge
alors si vous voulez me donner le vin
rouge
je vais commencer pour ne pas perdre
votre temps à m
rouge au chaud alors voyez vous les
pommes de terre sont en train de piocher
ici d'une façon absolument normal à vous
mettez dans un endroit très désagréable
pour le caméramans mais ça n'a pas
d'importance je lui dis simplement j'ai
mis du vin rouge dans une casserole et
ceci uniquement pour gagner du temps
peu importe que la caméra le voit on le
voit ici
non non c'était déjà d'ailleurs
alors voyez vous ici j'ai plus du gras
de jambon ou tricher 1
parce que quand vous m'avez donné la
recette mois vis du beurre et de lui on
peut mettre du beurre et de l'huile on
peut aussi mettre du bon moment et c'est
en regardant a toujours une émission sur
le pays basque que j'ai pensé que
effectivement le gras de jambon est une
chose merveilleuse et on doit y passer
alors j'ai pensé que je n'en parlais pas
c'est souvent elle se sera de jambon
souvent ne sais pas quoi en faire
eh bien on peut en faire d'excellence
hausse alors on peut le râpé ou bien
comme je viens de faire et qu'on peut le
couper en tout petits morceaux
alors on garde la noix de jambon pour en
faire les omelettes dépit prades enfin
tout ce que l'on voudra est par contre
le gras dont on ne sait souvent par quoi
faire peut servir à préparer les sauces
alors nous allons le mettre à fondre ici
dans une heure de grand une autre
casserole
non l'autre casseroles celle dans
laquelle j'ai mis le bain rouge n'est là
uniquement que pour nous faire gagner un
peu de temps c'est à dire faire chauffer
le vin de façon à ce que le divin j'ai
mis un tout petit peu de divin et c'est
merveilleux évident
bon je mange je me rendrai naître en 1/2
oignons et une petite bosse enfin j'ai
pris la plus grosse part écoutez moi
c'est ce à quoi s'est pour la sauce
alors ceci est pour la jambe à tous
alors pendant que ça va cuire que ça va
blondir et que les pommes de terre poche
allons nous en occuper
naturellement destin même salle et vous
le dire
oser plus je me disais va pas être
question de bien là dedans si ça va vite
oh oui alors oui ou là nous avons
maintenant on sait que c'est toujours
pas refermé
je sais comment vous faut je savais que
ça peut se faire
on sait à tout doucement beaucoup
justement tout le monde sait bien
s'entourer
je sais pas bon alors là et je m'en vais
avec un couteau un peu plus gros mais le
foyer où j'ai les coupés en deux comme
ceci je m'en vais l'écraser vous avez
d'ailleurs raison j'aime beaucoup la il
n'a fait quand ça alors c'est taille que
nous avons d'écraser je mens avec le pas
chez un tout petit peu tout de même
ça sent le mélange est le dieu sait si
on le mélange l'union mais on n'a pas
une grande importance pour le moment je
le h a pas qu'ils aient fait alors le
vin rouge est en train de bouillir corps
conséquent quel vin si tu veux un rouge
là en l'occurrence vous savez la sauce
bordelaise contrairement à ce que l'on
pourrait supposer est faite avec du vin
blanc met enfin à bordeaux dans la
région bordelaise
on aime beaucoup la sauce au vin rouge
jeu parce que sa sauce au vin rouge qui
va de la soupe à la halle aux hausses
les plus banales harry que le journal
parce que la loi vous allez quand même
pas sortir une bonne bouteille de
bordeaux pour faire ça c'est bien
évidemment ce ne serait pas une bonne
bouteille je pense que toutes les
bouteilles de bordeaux sont bonnes et
pas comme toutes les bouteilles de vin
français derrière mais je ne suis non on
voulait parler d'une très grande
modestie alors je le pense pas que cela
soit utile de sortir une très grande
bouteille de vin rouge
pour faire une sauce mais une bonne
bouteille je crois que c'est une
nécessité absolue
on ne peut pas penser faire une bonne
séance jeudi reste avec du mauvais vin
alors voyez vous nous allons laisser un
peu mijoter ceci du wima l'ajustement
java trop doucement et je m'en vais un
tout petit peu active et et en le
changeant et ça va trop doucement à
raison du temps dont vous disposez vous
bien non ça va se doteront doucement
parce que ce chauffage et un peu moins
puissant que je ne pensais c'est que
celui là alors voyez vous nous allons
les faire repartir et jonathan ne
présente aucun danger d'ailleurs non
alors on a vous avez naturellement il
faudrait pas que ça ait pour doucement
parce que si ça allait trop doucement
les pommes de terres colorées les unes
avec les autres et ça c'est tout à fait
désagréable est déjà arrivé ça qui est
très au courant alors la misère
le jeu était ce un peu symbolique il m'a
servi un tout petit peu aller plus vite
parce qu'en général affaires en général
en réalité j'aurais dû plutôt mettre une
goutte d'eau laisser bouillir aurait
laissé briller cette goutte d'eau
ajoutez donc le dollar l'or qui ont
répondu à ce moment là dans les
meilleures conditions
mais le show et son aurait pris en peu
de temps et pour gagner du temps j'ai
donc mis un tout petit peu de peur alors
voyez maintenant ici les pommes de terre
ont repris une cadence qui me plaît
davantage si vous êtes comme en scène
principale et puis maintenant gatlif
tout en gardant un oeil sur ce qui est
en train de passer là nous pourrions
peut-être si vous le voulez vous allez
mettre l'autre il y en avait deux on ne
voulait pas un autre angle et 6 me quand
je comprends que vous soyez inquiète
d'ailleurs une quête en ce qui concerne
cette petite sauce qui pourraient mon
bien brûler des coups pendant que nous
discutons mais je vais quand même parler
des steaks si vous le voulez bien aidé
surtout que là franchement dont nous
avez apporté 2 c à l'assortiment des
sternes
ah oui et aucun de ces steaks non
du même morceau il y a donc c'est donc
véritablement un assortiment alors que
vous connaissez moi je n'en connais que
trois noms je les connais pas tous alors
ça je sais que ces deux-là travers
pouvoir pourri ça je sais que c'est la
bavette parce que voyez-vous la valette
est strié regardez regardez comme elle
est strié l'est pas dans le sens de la
longueur
alors la voyez-vous l'estrie en les vois
je pense qu'on les voit très bien
d'ailleurs
en les écartant comme ça ils boucher dit
souvent que c'est leur morceau c'est
leur morceau ceci est le rom steak alors
leurs come stay que ça ce n'est pas le
morceau du gaucher mais par contre celui
ci est articulé lance alors en steak
chez nous on appelle ça le crew tue on
le reconnaît parce qu'effectivement
voyez vous il y a comme une croûte au
dessus c'est un morceau qui est prolonge
en quelque sorte le contrat filé
jusqu'au à la cuisse en quelque chose
comment son intermédiaire entre ces deux
morceaux là je regarde alors l'europe
c'est tout le monde connaît un steak et
quant à l'araignée ça c'est un morceau
très très extraordinaire l'arrêt c'est
le morceau du boucher c'est un morceau
qui se trouve à l'intérieur de l'os du
quasi le saint lô du casif chez les
petits animaux comme l'agneau ou le
mouton est minuscule mais rendent en
possédant assez considérable et à
l'intérieur de cette hausse il ya ce
qu'on a ce qui s'appelle l'araignée et
qui est le morceau en général que le
boucher réserve où son usage personnel
ça pas pour ses bons clients au dessus
et on ne peut pas tout manger alors il
est alors les autres vous prétendez vous
ne les connaissez pas je le prétends à
gérer je ne peux pas vous dire que je
les connais car ça serait mentir aux
bestiaux n'est pas de lunettes si
j'avais une
alors merci catherine je vous dis alors
ça c'est de l'aiguillette parole comme
c'est un oui c'est pour saclay les
lunettes ne sont nécessaires
ce n'est pas pour reconnaître le morceau
c'est pour ligue d'aquitaine moi ça
ressemble un petit peu ça y ressemble
oui mais c'est tout de même beaucoup
plus en quelque sorte et pc conclut
consistant c'était un morceau qui doit
être délicieux jus des citrons confits
certains métiers certainement beaucoup
moins de temps reconnaît le rom steak ça
ça s'appelle le merlan alors je crois je
crois pouvoir vous dire que si ça
s'appelle le maire
là c'est parce qu'effectivement ça à la
forme d'un poisson rouge est l'élu soit
ses enfants doivent associer toute la
caractéristique voulu donner c'est à mon
avis c'est la seule que je puisse celui
déterminé
bon et maintenant nous passons à ça moi
je peux lire âge alors ça mais
maintenant manqué des mois j'ai des
lunettes je peux lire dès que j'étais
honnête je lis alors ceci c'est la poire
la poire pourquoi la poire et le fromage
c'est le morceau que l'on sait c'est
tout ce que je vois qui a écrit poires
et je m'en avait fait nature certaines à
auch et moi alors là ça alors c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué alors ça vous
sert à lunettes
de plus ne sert donc plus à rien achevé
changer si vous voulez bien
les pommes de terre et duquel de ses
morceaux à les viser à vie et bien si
vous voulez je vais garder suis là
qu'est ce qu'il a dans vous et puis le
merlan cité qui me séduit par sa forme
est alors voyez vous ici
nous avons maintenant l'oignon et l'ail
qui sont bien revenus qui sont bien
blanc et que nous allons pouvoir
mouiller avec le verbe
alors nous avons l'avantagé évidemment
que ce vin rouge soit très chaud et par
conséquent nous n'avons pas de perdre de
temps alors à côté de vous ou plus
exactement au dessous de la table du
thym et du laurier catherine je peux
enlever les petits papiers maintenant
vous pourriez l'enlever je crois que oui
maintenant je suis sûr de ne plus me
tromper je dois tout de même précisé
catherine que vous êtes d'accord que il
s'agit la fellation de la région
parisienne
je ne voudrais pas que les bouchers
marseillais où les bouchers comment
dirais-je de cette strasbourgeois ou
non c'est un tribut si jamais ce n'est
pas ça du tout vous avez parlé de choses
que vous ne connaissez pas je ne les
connaissais d'ailleurs pas à 5 minutes
c'est qu'elle reconnaisse enfin
maintenant je me suis référé la
boucherie parisienne
alors j'aime y voyez-vous des branches
de thym que j'ai émietté à l'intérieur
de cette sauce et puis la moitié d'une
feuille de laurier
je peux aussi ajouter et ceci parce que
plaisait sous la main un clou de girofle
et alors on a fait du pouvoir bien
entendu et du sel qui doit-être où là
c'est très chaud alors voulait voir la
gentillesse de me donner le sait pas
gérer jusqu'à vous l'ouvrira temps déjà
voilà vous n'avez pas dit assez pour le
poids voyez j'ai continué j'attendais
avec impatience était vraiment c'est pas
moi qui ne l'avait pas fait alors je me
suis arrêté - veron en noyer ça peut
arriver
alors là la sauce et terminer enfin été
emmené en en os elle va cuire doucement
jusqu'à ce que nous ayons la possibilité
de l'allier c'est à dire dans quelques
minutes
alors là nous allons écouter ses formes
de cette taille elles sont cuites les
son plaidoyer vous souffle même ah oui
ils sont gonflés
elle souffle voyait quand on veut pas
qu'elle souffle et le souffle quand on
voudrait faire des pauses ou plus voulez
vous me donnez le sel je vous prie alors
là je vais vous faire un cadeau deux
assiettes je vais salessy steak et où
les salles et comme ceux ci de chaque
côté avant puissant avant cuisson là et
puis je m'en vais aussi les poivrer bien
fait pour cette recette en conséquence
que se servir de l'un ou l'autre de tous
ces morceaux très nombreux oui c'est
même notre jeu j'ai pas fais voir toutes
les possibilités intéresse je l'espérais
je voudrais que vous me donniez une
assiette et que vous me donniez un peu
d'huile alors je crois que maintenant il
va falloir tout de même que je me
dépêche suit l'on peut alors cinq
minutes me suffiront je l'espère alors
un tout petit peu d'huile le voyez vous
dans laquelle je vais passer comme ceci
laisse texte qui n'est pas une usine en
sol est resté pas non et puis sur le
grill immédiatement on peut les faire la
poche dernier les poils également dans
le cas où vous auriez exigé que les
centres sportifs car il est possible
allez vous aimez l'asie
on peut aussi faire cuire les steaks
dans une fois ce n'est plus du tout
alors pendant un concert gratuit comme
envers chauffer l'huile pour pouvoir
tromper les formes et avoir une très
bonne coloration et puis je mangeais si
vous le voulez bien faire la liaison
alors donnez moi c'est sa définition sur
un petit pécule donnez moi une
association autre thème c'est ça
tout ce qui gêne au bruit à la volée
vous une une pointe de couteau était qu
un tout petit peu de vin rouge que vous
voulez me passer voilà j'ai envoyé mon
[Musique]
jeu parce que de toutes façons de bâton
il est très agréable d'être aidé n'est
ce pas désagréable des [ __ ] et aussi
aussi je pense que les hommes aiment
bien montrer à leurs compagnes qu'ils
sont capables de faire quelque chose de
pas trop ces 4 c'est toujours agréable
d'être admiré et aimé des misères aux
non non non
cinq ans ça va vite c'est plus sur ce
point
voyez-vous là nous les allons laisser
cuire comme ceci alors maintenant
je ne peux rien vous et le plaquent
nombreuses et le platine ont servi à
présenter le la totalité de notre
préparation alors voyez vous la saur 6 6
en effet s'il continue à cuire doucement
et nous allons hors du peut tout à
l'heure j'ai incorporé un tout petit peu
de beurre alors nous laissons plus
holistique de l'onr tromper les formes
d'écriture la être assez chaude
attendait envoie ses entités sait où et
pas tout à fait encore mais ça va pas
tarder 1
alors vous aussi vous être regardée
comme l'effort ne sont pas prêts du tout
l'espace et on pourra vous faire
l'expérience grande ruine pour faire
voir rebellez vous tant qu'elles ne sont
pas trop choses incroyables je me brûle
on topic
croyez vous regardez allons nous allons
l'écraser allons l'ouvrir
ceci devant la caméra et puis l'écrasé
foyer comme elle est bien cuite à
l'intérieur des très très chaude sur ce
livre in est un engin stoïquement je
n'ai rien dit mais la lèvre là alors
maintenant nous allons l'avoir trompé en
lui donnant la couleur nécessaire alors
voyez que c'est une recette extrêmement
simple extrêmement facile à réaliser
délicieuse bien entendu puisque c'est
presque le plat national français son
point de vue c'est d'ailleurs lors ce
qu'à l'étranger on les resteront veulent
présenter un plat français
ils présentent généralement le coq au
vin le steak country et quoi encore la
conel lyonnaise je m'ennuie c'est que
chez eux le steak frites n'a jamais
lassant vert qu'il a chez nous c'est
l'ensemble qui est une certification de
différent mais c'est absurde je ne dis
pas de mal du tout du tout d'aucuns ne
fait pas d'eux
spécialisation enfin c'est l'un ou
l'autre mais c'est vrai voyez pas vous
qui avez beaucoup plus voyager que moi
en france et à l'ensemble inimitable mes
hommages d'excellence tech ailleurs sur
écoute et ensuite c'est strictement sa
vallejo et d'essayer catherine
alors voici j'espère que ça prenne qui
sont non ça ne traîne pas trop
voilà ils sont poivrez salez poivrez
salez grillé et presque quadrillée en
tout cas déjà marqué alors je m'en vais
égouttez euros je m'éloigne dans un
article là je vais me débarrasser de
gris pour les enveloppes ici je retire
la sauce du feu c'est extrêmement
important est hors du feu je m'en mets
salés
hors du feu bien entendu salle et les
formes comme ceux ci en les remuant par
terre comme ça oui c'est d'ailleurs que
si il tombe quelque chose ça tombe par
terre mais ce n'est qu'un peu de sel car
toute l'huile a été écouté alors voyez
vous ici et là le présente pour 2
personnes de steak de personnes de foi
là on dégageait un tout petit peu comme
ceux ci et là dans cette sauce nous
allons ajouter comme ceux ci un petit
morceau de beurre pour lui donner de
l'onctuosité aller hors du feu j'ai fait
absorber un peu de pratique encore un
petit peu de beurre voyez je vais le
mettre en deux fois celui ci il ne faut
pas en mettre trop à la fois en trente
secondes vous nous dites
et voilà trente secondes alors trente
secondes pour appeler la recette nous
faisons d'abord des pommes que nous
coupons en espèces de petites pyramides
et que nous faisons d'abord crochet et
ensuite colorés pour qu'elle soit bien
joli bien
doré nous faisons une sauce avec une
échalote ou un oignon un peu d'ail 2 du
jambon ou celle là fait c'est au bar
kuyl hébert nous faisons aussi fan et je
voudrais nous faisons un puits recettes
échalotes oignons avec l'ail
une fois que c'est bien que nous
ajoutons des vins rouges nous mettons un
peu de temps un peu de lauriers du sel
et du poivre
et puis nous laissons cuir avec du vin
rouge pendant environ un quart d'heure
après ce quart d'heure en nous faisant
une liaison avec une pointe de couteau
de fécule et un tout petit peu de vert
rouge à nouveau et puis hors du feu nous
ajoutons d'hubert nous saisissons les
steaks a peu d avoir saler poivrer
nous les retournant sur le grill de
façon à ce qu'ils soient cuits des deux
côtés et puis nous servons d'une part le
steak avec la sauce au dessus et les
pommes à chaque conte jack nous mettons
à table et nous nous disons d'un appétit
et merci heureusement sa tâche avec les
sept recettes compte pour le concours de
la cuisine pour déshabiller pas bon
appétit est vraiment
[Musique]